O D RN THE NT  PERFORMANCEIN FRT
PUBERTY BLOCKERS AND AND NOW TH
T IFIES T20-YEAR-D POSTS
PROVE PICTURES OF HIMSEL
>>EARR -- ASAI
>> Reporter: TENNESSEETENANT GO
McNALLY A REPUBLICAN AND
SUPPOROF
REPEATEDONWI OS
YOUNG GAN WHO POST
PROVOCOS ON INSTAGRAM.
THE PRSSE WEBSITTHNN UTH
McNALLY'S INTERACTIONS WITH
EA WHO
SOCIAL MEDIA.PERSTAR ON
IN MANY  McCLURE'S POSTS H
SCANTILY CLAFTIS
TLY DOWN.ONG E POSTS THE 79-Y
EUNOR REACcCLURE'S BACK
SIDE.
ONDED WITH THREE
HEARTS AND THREE FIRIES EN A
RAINHINE.
McNALLY DECL
AFFILIWTBF.
AND YOU KNOW,M IF CAN.OW EXACTI
ING FRANKLINRES ES WERE
ABOUT LIKI WHERE
EDE SUCH ATUND REFERRE A >> IT T
GOVERNcN
>> I KNOW , YOKNOW, ON PEOPLE'E
THAT POSY'VE YOUJUST B SAY>> Re
L READING THE  AUT
I KNOW Reporter: WHAT ABOUTHPROT
APPROPRIATE TO LIKE E COMMENT?>
TOLD MLIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
HAS BEEN COMMENTING ONIS
FOR SEVERAARS.ON THIS POST RESP
WITH THE COMMENT SUPERK.
ON THIS T
HEART EMOJI.
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LEFT A
COMMENT SAYINGWITHINHEARTSOLepo
ABOUT OFT BUT THER
THAT IS BECAUSE AT THEE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOS
S Q OPITICS  STE  OW REPUBLICANI
HATE.AS NOT VERKIND TCOMMUND
COMMUNITY REALIZED THEY'RETI
ILL HAVE
VALUE.
>> ReporteUS THERNOR HERE SIGNET
BARSRAGE
TT AFFIRMING
HEALTH
DEMOCRATIC STATE SENATOR HEIDI
>> I THINK IT IS PROBLEMATICT L
E PARTICIPATING IN BEHAVIOR
THAT OBVIOUSLY SHOWS TT VE INTT
>> Rte
DOZEN BILLS PROP
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS THAT LIMI
THE RIGHTS OTHOSE IN LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
RI TO ASK LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR McNAL A ALL OF
THIS AT THE L IN
WHAT DO YO FOLKS WHO AREG YOU A?
NEWS OST BRONDWHEASE.
PUSHED BACK.
I ALSO HAVE FRIEND THAE GAY.
Y TOLD ME AY.r: MEANWHILE, FRANH
LABY THE LIEUTENANT GOOR A.
ED M
ONN
APPSte
TO
I KNOW HE DID ,
>> Reporter: WE
>> I
>> I'V FAMILY,
D DSD ANY HE
HELAREH
PO
>>AN JOINSW INTENT ANDMY INTTH
NASHVILLE.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOY. SAID SOMET.
>> Repor ISSUE A STATEMENT,
ITE A LO
STATEMENT. GKEPARTS.
HE SAID HE IS G HIAL
GUIDANCE TE E GETTING
HE INSISTED THIS CHARACRI AS INE
REGARDLESD EV PERSON HAS VA
OF ORIENTA BUTANSO
ASNOW ISOMESE CONTINUES TO PH
THISNTI-GAGISLATION.ACT JUST TOO
TH WE DEBATING  SEX BILL WHILE
TO SPEAK WITH HIM.
FRANKLIN McCLURE THE YO
MAN HEN COMMENTING ON ON
STE HYPOCRISY
IN ALL OF THIS WAS NOT LOST ON
HIM
HE S HE'HING HIM E THESRYE COMM